[Music]
in a franchise with zero new ideas okay
one New Idea Star Wars Will Stop drawing
from the classics in favor of those
cartoons that came on after Ben 10 has
your taste matured since then no all
right then who wants to see some
lightsaber
tricks
[Music]
how
inevitable
Ahsoka get ready for a NOS back to basic
Star Wars Adventure light sides and dark
sides x-wings and Tie fighters and C
droids and Aliens begging for the sweet
release of merch click the shop tab to
learn more but what really makes Ahsoka
feel like that George Lucas original
recipe is some of the worst dialogue
since I don't like sand don't worry
about me I'm
not good should I
be
what
worried nope uh I'm joking you're joking
yeah I'm joking how can you joke at a
time like this what would you prefer I
don't know you want me to be more
serious I prefer it stop I burned my
life to make a sunrise that I know I'll
never see hey that was from Andor you're
right just
wish she had changed a little that's
ahoka is that a stingray trying to eat
Tony the Tiger no it's Ahsoka Tano a
compelling character as long as you
don't count her first movie you're stuck
with me Sky guy what did you just call
me or this entire show all right
then watch her cross her arms and
monotone every word tell me what's going
on and fight like someone who's afraid
her tentacles will fly off if she moves
too fast this absolute Charisma hole
will meet her match in Sabine Ren a
rebel straight out of rebellious
characters Incorporated complete with
purple hair Speeder bike and dual Jedi
Mandalorian backstories like some kind
of pirate ninja alone they're boring
together they'll have the chemistry
you'd expect of 2x co-workers on a road
trip that will have fans everywhere
wandering
which one of them can sigh
more the student has become the
master long ago in a galaxy that's
surprisingly clean now our heroes must
stop the bad guys from building a portal
to all the garbage hanging out of in the
Star Wars extended Universe to do that
they must boldly solve a bunch of stupid
puzzles find the key looking for a key
okay Crack the
[Music]
Code unlock the mini map and fast travel
to the whale Point Intergalactic travel
within a star whale now I really have
done it all to rescue their buddies
space Jesus do you think no the force is
my Ally across eight episodes that are
light on Story by TV standards but just
just enough to fill an RPG fetch Quest
oh cool they unlock the blade of talin
does the damage scale with strength or
decks finally gaze upon liveaction
thrawn and his liveaction dad got also
does the Empire not have a tailor what's
going on here gr Smurf taret over here
is the heir to the Empire with a plan to
raise an army slightly less dangerous
than
butter but to do that he must team up
with Morgan the space wh bch too hang on
they have space witches now you're a
witch an ancient people from a distant
Galaxy okay so not witches just Ancient
Aliens witchcraft or witches so witches
my people were among the first to
harness and ride the creatures in the
days before time was counted okay you
win I stopped carrying plus bringing
some small shred of light to the dark
side is Balin skull and the little
sister he picked up along the way your
ambition drives you in One Direction
Direction take your place in the coming
Empire and wanders around resigned to
his fate speaking for the Star Wars fans
trapped watching the same old drag it
repeats again and
again and
again extend your big red Sabers for the
return of Anakin Skywalker Hayden
Christensen is back and eerily smoother
than ever to play Ghost dad to Ahsoka in
an extremely orange flashback I don't
know this battle his Redemption Park is
finally complete not because he
apologized for being space Hitler no
it's just enough time has passed that
we're happy to see him again nope nope
sorry still can't do it I hope ghost W
beats him with a shoe
by so get ready to pretend the last
decade never happened and wrap yourself
in a comforting blanket of 2014
Nostalgia just a little rusty for a show
that's giving out more fan service than
a sex worker at Celebration the night
sister of damir three
honored Chancellor a long time ago in a
galaxy far far away Jason has abilities
his father Kanan jarus was a
Jedi okay until it's clear this
franchise stalled out years ago and has
been slowly rotting in the belly of a
sarlac of its own
creation who wants to see some more
lightsaber tricks
huh
[Music]
de
starring Dawson's Creed Ren and snippy
Dr screw Twilight breaking thraw
Punisher star war zone Anya Taylor
misery which better have my map key
beards do not grow in space Any Given
Sunday once in a blue goon chivalry is
dead or two D nuts orange man good yamon
nine clinch snails an actual coven of
chaos and a perfect metaphor for Disney
Star
Wars Star Wars jumping the
whale oh oh right cuz he turns into
Darth Vader it's like poetry so they
rhyme hey screen Junkies you know who
needs therapy me you know who else
Spider-Man we asked a clinical
psychiatrist to put all movie versions
of Peter on the couch to see what makes
them tick in an all new episode click
the Box on the right to watch
now what the hell is an illuminum Falcon
Crush kill destroy swag Crush kill
destroy swag
welcome to the new new new new new new
new new new new new new new new new
worst game
ever